voilà quelques jours qu'on n'avait pas
entendu parler du professeur raoul et
cette fois ci c'est pour des raisons
judiciaires
en effet si didier raoul tu as un temps
été entendu par la commission d' enquête
du sénat pour ses déclarations lors de
la première vague de coronavirus c'est
lui aujourd'hui qui saisit les tribunaux
pour pouvoir continuer à utiliser
l'hydroxyde chloroquine comme remède
pour ces patients atteints par le cos
vide
on sait que pour lui il s'agit du
produit miracle comme il en a parlé de
nombreuses fois dans des vidéos le
traitement du corona ça va probablement
être la chloroquine avec 500 milliards
de zlotys par jour c'est la chloroquine
un avis que ne partage pas le pouvoir
exécutif
les dernières publications monsieur le
sénateur que je vous invite à lire ne
sont pas en faveur
hélas hydroxy chloroquine sous soir
fabrice michaud valant responsable de la
communication du professeur didier
raoult il est avec nous son ballon vous
avez vous vraiment désolé mais ressent
déjà d'avoir accepté d'avoir des
traitements toujours quand c'est sérieux
faut qu'il soit excusé nerveux alors
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de la
décision décision de ne pas autoriser le
professeur raoul sur son rôle à
l'encontre vous excusez moi je suis à
l'encontre de la mission et de
l'engagement qu'a pris le professeur
raoul tout justement pour mener à bien
toutes à toutes ces recherches puisque
le professeur rogue rappelé et pas
n'importe qui sa réputation a à
[Musique]
et au delà des frontières européennes à
nathan serment d'hippocrate dit il est
bien que chaque médecin soigne somme mal
à d'autres comme ils en fixent les
médicaments qu'ils abusent alors sachez
que moi le serment d'hippocrate
forcément je suis chargé de la
communication donc moi le domaine
médical je connais au regard de la
communication que que j'ai pour le
professeur raoul mais il se trouve que
en termes de gestion médicaux
effectivement là je laisse la parole aux
professionnels c'est une occurrence au
professeur ajoute jean michel c'est une
fois de plus c'est la preuve que sanaa
poster quelques elle a besoin d'un
directeur de la communication après il
est ministre il est président il croyait
directeur des communications au parc
sujet c'est normal vu le boulot qu'il a
le poste contre si le médecin du
quartier qui te soigner le malade à la
haine attaché de communication le 20 mai
comme il fait c'est comme il dit pas
comment ma croit en lui marquant la
taille variable malik le florent pagny
armés prenaient ce que vous dites est
sidérant le jeu sans faire n'importe
quoi ya pas d vous monsieur c'est encore
pire
y'a pas d'essais cliniques autorisé et
j'ai vu que professeurs ont menacé
d'attaquer au pénal d'origine illégale
d'intérêts à la ce moment là on fait
n'importe quoi nous plaît il en train de
dire aux uns et autres à disjoncter
totalement c'est ici il y en a beaucoup
critiquent le bol se rend à par
honeywell d'échangé pour auditer
d'insulter son plein et vous vous
défendez tout le temps professeur un jeu
comparable
il est attaqué et lui la taxe et qui
doit aborder déraisonne d'attaqué
d'abord des chargés de gérer comme
message pour rené alors effectivement
donc je suis chargé de sa communication
entre la communication du professeur
raoul tu es j'aurais effectivement enfin
en tout cas c'est la raison de la
présence ce soir non pas pour débattre
sur le programme est sûre on va dire la
communication est effectivement je
voudrais adresser un message si vous
voulez bien longtemps puisque votre
pseudo soutien si je fait dire au
professeur raout porte préjudice à bord
préjudice à sa crédibilité à la
crédibilité du professeur arbres ainsi
qu'à la craie demi ton de ces de ses
collaborateurs il se trouve que je
simplement regarder déjà votre t-shirt
vous avez une caricature du professeur
est comme la mienne à côté la vôtre vous
faites comme vous l'entendez me défends
touareg-- par rapport à la caricature du
professeur out qui est
internationalement que
internationalement connue est-ce que
vous pensez que cette communication
justement est approprié en levant et ben
moi j'aime comment vit-il comme ça et la
bougie qu'est ce que vous en pensez
la bougie il a encore les arts où il ne
veut pas qu'on parle de lui que n'aime
pas te comment qu'on en parle moi j'ai
toujours de temps déjà pour les médias
qu'on en parle en bien ou en mal
l'important est qu'on n'aime pas mais
moi ce t-shirt tymoschuk excusez-moi
excuse-moi rené tu peux tu peux me je
peux je peux dire à tous petits mots je
vous trouve d'une condescendance et
d'une suffisance qui dépasse
l'entendement
il a raison il a raison d'abord vous
êtes un directoire de la communication
de titres un médecin tu as dit à peu
près n'importe quoi kadio mois de juin
que c'est un gros chinois qu'il fallait
pas s'inquiéter
kadio mois de septembre que ce serait
nier
qu'a dit après qu'il y aurait pas de
deuxième bac que c'est éphémère djibouti
dit maintenant que la chloroquine soigne
pardonnez moi mais il est dit il est de
20 non seulement c'est une voyante
en plus d'être condescendant avec les
gens qu'ils soutiennent eh ben mon avis
vous avez plus en avoir beaucoup de
soupe chaude et si vous avez à répondre
non mais moi je ne dis pas dans le sens
qui l'habille lellouche mais le tout le
jour chez nous c'est vrai mais moi voilà
je soutiens le professeur à rouge à
marseille à notre façon et quand le
professeur raoul avait sa dacia parce
qu'il a qu'une dacia et raul
ils partent sur le jard les et que tous
les hommes en aveux qui berce l'habitat
et les chauffeurs de taxi avec les
fumigènes donc ce monsieur monsieur
michaud vous avez vous avez un message
croirait un instrument arguments j'ai un
message et le et de voici c'est quoi
voilà bien la toiture puis c'est
d'acheter shirt avec un message très
clair c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
m